les médecins libéraux manifestent
aujourd'hui à Paris plusieurs milliers
de personnes se sont donné rendez-vous
Place du Panthéon il réclame le
doublement du tarif de base et une
consultation à 50 euros au lieu de 25
aujourd'hui je sais pas parce que je
suis là qui sont grève c'est parce qu'il
y a cette négociation conventionnelle et
que chacun montre les muscles pour
obtenir un peu ce qu'il veut et bien
laissons cette négociation aller au bout
c'est jusqu'à fin février et sur ce
principe
gagnant-gagnant c'est à dire d'accord on
augmente la consultation ces tarifs des
mutuelles vont augmenter en moyenne de
4,7% cette année après 3,4 l'an dernier
c'est en partie parce que le 100% santé
pour les soins dentaires l'optique ou
encore les prothèses auditives et de
plus en plus utilisées il y a en France
une ivresse de la dépense publique
comme si la dépense publique
effaçait toute difficulté
réglait tout problème
enjoliver la réalité on a un nouveau
record en décembre dernier
72836 personnes sont incarcérées en
France aujourd'hui pour
60698 places officiellement ça veut dire
qu'on est à 120% des capacités
et elle conduit tout droit comme toutes
les ivresse que vous avez peut-être
connu il y a quelques jours pendant les
fêtes
un moment désagréable
qui la gueule de bois après Matignon
hier le mouvement dernière rénovation
s'attaque aujourd'hui à Bercy 2
militantes on asperger la façade du
ministère de peinture orange elles ont
été immédiatement interpellées la lutte
contre la surpopulation carcérale passe
également par la poursuite de
l'ambitieux plan voulu par le Président
de la République de construction de
15000 places de prison et pas normal qui
est des gens qui fassent des très gros
profits dans un moment où on utilise
quand même l'argent du contribuable pour
aider les plus petits à résister donc on
va remettre un peu tout le monde
d'équerre dans cette période plutôt que
d'aller bavasser sur les plateaux je
pense que le gouvernement ferait mieux
de se rendre à Berlin et à Bruxelles
pour aller défendre les intérêts de la
France et pour faire en sorte que la
courbe des prix devienne beaucoup plus
maîtrisable qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
et bien ce qu'on va demander dès
maintenant
au fournisseur d'énergie c'est de
revenir vers chacun de ces artisans
chacune de ces TPE et de les renégocier
pour les remettre dans le lit de la
rivière
incompréhensible ce qui est sorti de
Bercy
incompréhensible d'ailleurs le ministre
a tellement reconnu qu'il veut écrire à
chacun des boulangers de France pour
expliquer le dispo
tous les six mois Emmanuel Macron a une
épiphanie c'est vraiment scandaleux
c'est super profit c'est vraiment on va
y mettre un terme on va vraiment leur
regarder droit dans les yeux et vous
allez voir comment ils vont trembler
finalement qu'est-ce qui se passe rien
il y a pas de loi l'Assemblée nationale
il y a aucune décision qui est prise et
six mois après ça revient il faut bien
se mettre en tête qu'on ne pourra pas
aider tout le monde demain ce sera les
stations de ski sans neige après-demain
d'autres activités la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de marge
de manœuvre je voudrais rappeler que
nous avons dépensé entre le covid
l'inflation la crise énergétique 250
milliards Benoît fidèle ami du Christ
que ta joie soit entière en entendant sa
voix maintenant et pour toujours mais
contrairement à l'enterrement de tous
les papes que l'on a pu connaître il y a
pas de suspense il y a pas de danger
politique il y a pas de succession le
successeur il est déjà là c'est lui qui
préside la cérémonie Benoît XV est
ensuite inhumé en privé dans la crypte
de la basilique Saint-Pierre il n'y a
plus qu'un seul pape François au Vatican
cette expérience menée par un youtubeur
à Hong Kong la poussée à chercher une
solution pour rester au sec et il a
trouvé avec une fausse brique à la main
miracle
les conducteurs ralentissent et
contournent même les flaques d'eau